>>> NATIONAL COMING OUT DAY,
D.C. COMICS ANNOUNCED THE NEW
SUPERMAN, JONATHAN KENT, WILL BE
BISEXUAL.
KENT, THE CHILD OF CLARK KENT
AND LOIS LANE WILL EXPLORE HIS
IDENTITY AND OTHER SOCIAL ISSUES
IN THE NEW COMIC SON OF CALEL.
JOINING ME IS TOM TAYLOR, "NEW
YORK TIMES" BEST-SELLING AUTHOR.
I'M A COMIC BOOK JUNKIE.
I APPRECIATE YOU JOINING US.
TELL US ABOUT SUPERMAN AND HIS
FRIEND JAY NAKAMORO.
WHAT IS THEIR RELATIONSHIP LIKE?
>> THEIR RELATIONSHIP IF YOU'VE
SEEN THE PICTURES IS A CLOSE
ONE.
SUPERMAN IS NOT CLARK KENT.
I WANT TO MAKE THAT CLEAR FROM
THE GET-GO.
THIS IS JOHN KENT, THE SON OF
CLARK KENT AND LOIS LANE.
>> WHY?
WHY DID YOU MAKE THIS DECISION?
>> WHY DID I MAKE THIS DECISION?
WELL, WHEN I WAS OFFERED THE GIG
TO HAVE A NEW SUPERMAN AND A NEW
SUPERMAN NUMBER ONE FOR DC
COMICS, THAT'S A BIG THING.
AND I THINK THE FIRST QUESTION I
HAD TO ASK MYSELF WAS WHAT DOES
SUPERMAN -- WHAT SHOULD SUPERMAN
REPRESENT TODAY?
A NEW SUPERMAN, IF YOU MAKE A
NEW SUPERMAN, WHAT SHOULD THAT
LOOK LIKE?
IT STRUCK ME AS IT WOULD BE A
REAL OPPORTUNITY LOST IF WE HAD
ANOTHER -- WE HAD CLARK KENT
REPLACED BY ANOTHER STRAIGHT
WHITE SAVIOR.
SO HERE WAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CREATE A SUPERMAN WHO COULD
REPRESENT A WHOLE NEW GROUP OF
PEOPLE.
AND I THINK THAT WAS ONE THAT WE
HAD TO TAKE ON.
>> AND WILL BE ADDRESSING MODERN
DAY ISSUES LIKE --
>> LIKE THE CLIMATE CRISIS, LIKE
REFUGEES.
JOHN IN THE LAST ISSUE WAS JUST
ARRESTED ATTENDING A PROTEST,
TRYING TO STOP THE -- OF ASYLUM
SEEKERS.
AS A STAND, IT IS A VERY
POWERFUL THING.
AND, YES, SO THIS IS ONE OF THE
THINGS FOR HIM.
HE'S TRYING TO WORK OUT WHO HE
IS, WHO HE IS AS SUPERMAN, WHO
HE IS AS JOHN KENT AND US AS THE
WRITER AND EVERYONE AT DC COMICS
IS WATCHING HIM GO THROUGH THIS
PROCESS OF FINDING HIMSELF AND
SEEING THAT ON THE PAGE.
>> WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THOSE WHO
SAY SUPERMAN SHOULD BE FIGHTING
ROBOTS AND LASERS AND LEX LUTHER
AND THE LEGION OF DOOM, NOT
DEALING WITH THIS STUFF?
>> HE IS GOING TO BE -- I
PROMISE HE WILL PUNCH A ROBOT.
THAT'S A GUARANTEE.
HE WILL COME UP AGAINST LEX
LUTHER IN THE UPCOMING ANNUAL.
ALL THOSE THINGS ARE PART AND
PARCEL OF SUPERMAN AND THIS IS
JUST SOMETHING EXTRA THAT THAT
VERY IMPORTANT SYMBOL CAN NOW
REPRESENT.
AND I HAVE TO SAY, HAVING SEEN
THE REACTION TODAY, HAVING SEEN
ONLINE WHAT IT MEANT TO PEOPLE,
I'VE SEEN SO MANY MESSAGES FROM
ALL OVER THE WORLD AND SO MANY
DIFFERENT LANGUAGES, PEOPLE
SAYING THAT THEY SAW THIS NEWS
AND BURST INTO TEARS.
PEOPLE SAYING THEY NEVER THOUGHT
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO SEE
THEMSELVES IN SUPERMAN, THAT
THEY WISH OTHER PEOPLE WHO --
OLDER PEOPLE, ALL THE PEOPLE WHO
SAID THEY WISH THEY HAD THIS
GROWING UP AND THEY'RE SO HAPPY
THAT YOUNGER PEOPLE, PEOPLE WHO
HAVEN'T COME OUT YET, HAVE THIS
TODAY.
>> IT IS WONDERFUL THAT YOU'RE
GETTING THAT REACTION.
THERE IS ALSO SOME OF THE OTHER
TYPE OF REACTION, PARTICULARLY
HERE IN THE U.S., POLITICAL
REACTION.
BECAUSE EVERYTHING HAS GOT TO BE
POLITICAL NOW, INCLUDING PARENT.
THIS IS FROM WENDY ROGERS, WHO
IS A STATE LEGISLATOR IN
ARIZONA, WHO WROTE, SUPERMAN
LOVES LEWIS LANE, SHE WRITES.
PERIOD.
HOLLYWOOD IS TRYING TO MAKE
SUPERMAN GAY AND HE'S NOT.
I CANNOT STRESS THE LEVEL OF
IGNORANCE IN THIS TWEET, FIRST
OF ALL, BECAUSE SHE SPELLS LOIS
LANE, LEWIS, TO BEGIN WITH.
A.
AND, B, SHE SAYS THAT SUPERMAN
LOVES LOUIS LANE.
LOIS LANE IS HIS MOM.
HOW DEPRAVED IS THIS WENDY
ROGERS FROM ARIZONA?
>> RIGHT.
LOOK, I THINK -- I DON'T KNOW
WHETHER IT IS JUST BEING A
STRAIN, I READ THAT AS LOUIE
LANE.
WHOEVER LOUIE LANE IS, I HOPE
HE'S HAPPY.
WE'RE GOING TO GET SOME BACKLASH
FOR THIS, BUT THE KEY FOR ME
ISN'T THE PEOPLE THAT ARE UPSET,
IT IS FOR THE PEOPLE WELCOMED IN
BY THIS THAT SAY TODAY, YOU
KNOW, THIS IS MORE POWERFUL THAN
A LOCOMOTIVE.
THAT THIS IS LITERALLY THE MOST
POWERFUL SUPERHERO IN COMICS.
AND ONE OF THE BEST KNOWN ALL
AROUND THE WORLD IS NOW
BISEXUAL.
AND I THINK THAT'S A REALLY BIG
AND REALLY STRON